so let's pay attention at this DC Club
they start young does everyone have
their water bottle no
yeah
here to learn the basics
[Music]
and even the drama
the one thing they already know is what
to call the game they're playing
soccer soccer
but why would you not call a game that
you use playing your feet and a ball
football
well that's a good question I thought so
so I put it to these little experts if
we used our hands then we would call it
football but since we use our feet it's
not for fun because the balls have
different names and this ball is called
the soccer ball
soccer you use with your feet in the
socks on your feet people in America
um they they wanted to make it um
actually it's not an American word to
find out the source we spoke to the
people who actually wrote a book about
this it all started when the first
football rules were written in 1863 at
this London pub naming the sport
association football from there Oxford
students with a penchant for adding ER
to words made it up at Oxford University
it was all pretty much all the kind of
semi-aristocracy at the time so those
kinds of people were associated with
doing these kind of things so they
wouldn't call it breakfast
they'd call it
uh bricka so in short they couldn't
really add an ER to the beginning of
Association so they went with a middle
part instead soccer they found evidence
it was commonly used in the United
Kingdom up to around the 70s and then it
just stopped it is such an interesting
question right how uh a country or
culture decides to Orphan one of its own
words we could not find a single
parallel case of this there are words
that fall out of fashion right or that
used to be common then we decide they're
offensive and so they're taboo but we
cannot think of a single case where a
country says this is not our word here
in DC the word is proudly claimed
um
in American football there are like two
players that ever use their feet on this
ball so should it change would football
make more sense if you ask these kids
it's a unanimous nope not in the USA
Patty culhane Al Jazeera Washington
[Music]